voilà alors quand je vous parlais d'une
surprise tout à l'heure la voici la
surprise
vous ne vous rendez peut-être pas tout à
fait compte de la taille mais là vous
allez vous en rendre compte en nous
voyant c'est le plus gros joueur du
monde bernard alors françois avec la
chaque mardi nous il va pas s'en aller
comment s'appelle-t-il c'est un capybara
un capybara c'est le plus gros rongeur
du monde qui vit en amérique du sud
il doit peu à peu près 50 kg c'est très
lourd c'est très dense ouais c'est un
animal qui vit actuellement c'est pas un
animal préhistorique
il annonce en tout cas envoyé sa vie en
troupeau d'une vingtaine d'individus qui
s'en va la liberté et ils vivent en
liberté il adore l'eau ces animaux qui
plombe c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
pour les animaux passer d'une horreur
les animaux puis plonge
j'en sais rien il m'a juste aspergé de 2
litres de pipi et alors allez y
continuez je vous en prie époque là je
t'en fous de caresser je pense à le
caresser oui c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est aussi le pas et vous
n'êtes pas des stages et non pas partout
où il est passé
attention oui alors bien mais il fait
votre commentaire donc c'est un animal
qui vit doucement doucement nous foutons
georges gonon c'est un animal qui vit en
amérique du sud
c'est à cette image
ça va bien mais mon modèle c'est après a
tellement peur
quand il faudrait faire tout petit comme
endemol est peut-être la moins de bruit
pour éviter de les choyer parce qu'il
faudrait pas non plus qu'il soit
malheureux
donc voilà si on se calme un peu je
pense que mike et y en avait un qui vit
qui vit au parc zoologique de thoiry wii
qui est habitué à voir du monde mais au
contraire est absolument pas pleurer
puisqu'il n'a pas peur d'eux les spots
qui a pas peur des caméras bon il va
engager un peu quoi qu'ils pensent mais
l'habituelle vivre en liberté à l'avouer
il n'y a pas de traces prof c'est un peu
mouvementée au lycée bien c'est bon je
voulais simplement réduit maintenant
c'est vrai moi vous ne l'auriez 10 jeux
nes gagnants s'ils avaient simplement
profité pour donner quelques conseils
sur les rongeurs jambon puisque les
rangeant ses actionnaires pour moi c'est
quand même oui il vaut mieux pas voir
l'appartement guerre externe a fait du
dégât alors